we've already reviewed the PlayStation 4
and Xbox one versions of Grand Theft
Auto 5 which we found to be stunning who
praised the game at large not only for
its visuals but for the quality of the
writing and acting as well it's a
virtual playground filled with creative
scenarios that cover a wide gamut of
activities all of which are crafted with
an admirable level of care now that the
PC version is out there's an entirely
new way to experience Grand Theft Auto 5
with another bump in visuals but also
new controls in a surprise video editing
feature
at its core Grand Theft Auto 5 on PC is
the same game that is on other platforms
and while it's never looked as good as
it does on a strong PC anyone who's
played it before may not benefit from
buying it for a second or third time
unless they're desperate for better
graphics if you fall into that camp you
can easily transfer your progress over
to the PC version via the Rockstar
social club to continue where you left
off diving headlong into the revamp to
Los Santos with minimal fuss Grand Theft
Auto 5 looked great on PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one but it shines on PC thanks to
4k grade textures the availability of
additional post-processing effects and
an unlocked framerate previous versions
of the game played just fine at 30
frames per second but you quickly
appreciate the added fluidity of playing
it at 60 frames per second on PC if you
can give it enough juice read afford
top-end gaming hardware then you can
marvel at the added flourishes in 4k but
even three and Vidia GTX 980 s and sli
couldn't push the highest settings at 4k
without dipping to around 30 frames per
second whether it's in 4k or at 1080p
the new high-res textures pop with
detail and new lighting effects lead the
plenty of awe-inspiring moments Grand
Theft Auto 5 can paint stunning pictures
with the right mix of scenery subject
and daylight that highly the natural
beauty of its geography and the grime
that pulses through its concrete bins
Grand Theft Auto 5 has always looked
good but a great gaming PC is the only
way to witness the full extent of
rockstars admirable handiwork keep in
mind however that grand theft auto 5
retains evidence of its last gen roots
even on PC with simple geometry abound
you notice low-polygon models on
occasion as they contrast with the great
texture work and lighting on hand as
simplicity and complexity mix before
your eyes grand theft auto 5 is
impressive at times but you never forget
that you're playing a game that's
foundation was built with outdated
constraints feel I gotta go I'm out
ah that's wrong you get a unique tool in
the PC version that allows you to show
off all the game's Flair as well as your
creativity the Rockstar editor this tool
allows you to record footage during
missions or while free roaming around
Los Santos either by manually recording
gameplay or by sourcing the last few
minutes of cached actions more than
simply allowing you to cut together
clips you have full control over the
camera while going through your gameplay
you can set your angles manually choose
from a list of preset angles and apply
camera shakiness redefining the look and
perspective
a moment in time little touches such as
blending make it easy to transition from
one clip and camera angle to the next
without having to put too much thought
into it in director mode you have even
more control over the events at hand
you can choose actors human or animal to
control rather than being limited to the
three main characters in the game you
also have control over the time of day
your location on the map and whether or
not cheats are enabled allowing you to
sample from a wide palette of
possibilities to craft the scene of your
dreams there's a learning curve to the
editor but rockstar offers a range of
tutorial videos that should help
experienced and inexperienced editors
alike playing Grand Theft Auto 5 on PC
means that you can now use a mouse and
keyboard which is a huge benefit during
shootouts where precision is key whether
you play it in first or third person
mode it clearly makes target and easy
however don't think that you should put
down the controller for good keyboard
and mice lack analogue buttons which are
key during driving sequences being able
to control your throttle with a
sensitive trigger is something you get
used to and manage naturally often
without giving it a second thought the
binary on or off nature of a keyboard or
mouse gets in the way of your instincts
and takes away the nuanced control
afforded by analog triggers for the best
experience keep a controller plugged in
and switch between it and a mouse and
keyboard for the moment at hand chalk it
up to hardware standards rather than
rockstars
for ongoing coverage of Grand Theft Auto
5 and our reviews for both the
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one versions of
the game stay tuned to game spot calm